what does tick tock gather from a user
but gathers quite a bit it requests
access to your camera your microphone
your photos your videos contacts
location information and a look at your
general activity online your so-called
online Behavior but all this isn't all
that different from what every other
major social media company asks for now
Tick Tock also tracks you as you move
around the web it uses something called
pixel trackers which are common to every
other web company where little tiny
images embedded in the websites you look
at and even some of the emails you
receive give the company an indication
that you were there this allows them to
understand your presence on the internet
now this recently caused some concern in
the U.S when a Canadian security company
called faroot found Tick Tock trackers
built into some government websites even
in States that had banned Tick Tock from
government devices the government said
they didn't know that those trackers
were there but this is all part of the
architecture of the web that we know
today we're tracked by the companies
that advertise to us because that's what
funds the whole system Tick Tock will be
challenged to explain where this data is
going Americans and Europeans want their
data to stay in their territories Tick
Tock has proposed solutions to this
project clover in Europe project Texas
in the United States billion dollar
programs to house the user's data in the
territories where they live and have
Consultants from those countries review
the way the data is used
whether or not any of this satisfies
lawmakers is really a political question
not a technical one Tick Tock has built
a program that users love to use it's
extremely engaging and that's because it
uses their data extremely well whether
they're allowed to continue in countries
that aren't China is up to politicians
[Music]